let's pull up this uh this tweet here
now I'm not I'm not sure if this is
confirmed that I don't know but you guys
have probably seen it all over the place
this is from stux on Mastodon he says
what's it with people reporting every
single person they don't like please
stop with that this is not Twitter
please use features like mute or block
if you don't like people but stop
reporting otherwise I'll start Banning
people who keep reporting for nothing
I'm trying to keep things running with
so many new people and it's such a waste
of time to hear whatever you don't like
otherwise go waste elon's time not mine
Elon Musk tweeted please Hall monitors
go on someone else's platform it was
Nate silver who said that he thinks
Mastodon is a Honeypot for the hall
monitor types all of these people on
Twitter who report everything and won't
shut up are leaving and going to Macedon
and all Spider-Man meme pointing at each
other and uh we're all having a good
time it's like there's a party going on
and they left so you know I'll take it
how many employees have been slashed so
far at Twitter
point where like they don't have as many
moderators
then no moderators none no I'm not I'm
pretty sure their moderation team's gone
they've got to have some people no I I
think because they've like they've now
like streamlined the process for
reporting child exploitation materials
which I have been waiting for them to do
for so long because they made it
unnecessarily difficult you had to go
through on the desktop version uh and go
through a longer process to do that so
they they streamlined that process they
have to have a good moderation team to
keep up with that and there's been like
I've seen reports that they're are doing
a Crackdown on child exploitation yeah
he's the number one priority he said but
you can't do that without moderators and
that's true good point I mean before the
moderators were just like acting like
demagogues
about you know
not if you were having a conversation
with someone and you weren't being
academic enough in your language then
you would get banned pretty much right
well there it is there's also you're
just at the mercy of like any random
individual that comes across this let me
say real quick since the uh
beginning of the election month or
whatever like October and then we're
getting into November
all of my videos pertaining to election
issues have been demonetized for fake
reasons
and it's it costs a lot of money it
really does like getting getting you
know when you when when you know I cut
down the amount of videos I do I went
from uh what was I doing like six to
three
having one it's it's it's bad it's a lot
of money yeah and what happens is I'll
get the yellow dollar sign and then I'll
I'll request review which takes a day
you get all the views in your day then
you get no money
if it is confirmed like the next day
it'll say confirmed demonetized by
manual review and it will say harmful or
dangerous activity and it's me reading a
poll and being like the polls are in and
they say this that and then I gotta call
Google and then they're like whoops that
was an accident let's fix it for you and
I'm like who are you employing who's
lying on all of them they're clearly
leftists yes well it happens to every
one of my videos but I have no one to
call so like you saw my stats you saw my
income it's absolutely insane what's
happening on my YouTube channel But to
answer your question there's also a lot
of third-party companies uh usually a
lot of international workers that get
hired to do a lot of this moderation
some of the moderation is done in-house
but a lot of it is done through of
course other private companies in Africa
in Asia where of course the labor there
is a lot cheaper and we and and this has
been documented many times even with
project Veritas project Veritas even
released an expose talking about how
Twitter employees were paid to view at
everything including private messages
people's posts how Twitter Engineers
were there to of course Implement Shadow
Banning this is Project Veritas talking
to Twitter Engineers that were bragging
about having Trump's private DM messages
and were threatening to release them so
again when we look at that content
moderation when we look at the
destruction of speech we have so much
power by so many few individuals that
absolutely use it and abuse it for the
worst Sinister political purposes and if
you dare to speak outside of the
established narratives you're going to
get punished you're going to get screwed
over and that's exactly what's happening
to to my YouTube channel in such an
extensive way there's another dimension
of demonetization that is very relevant
to elon's predicament with Twitter and
that is the latest scam of brand safety
which is basically like a mafia
Shakedown because in some cases they
have third world Imports in some cases
they just have
um just you know uh regular people but
what they do is they basically tell tell
these advertising agencies they say you
know you're you're at your advertisement
with this site is a really inappropriate
for your brand I think you should
reconsider and if you don't it would be
a shame if something happened to you and
they have a whole infrastructure in
place to make good on their threat and
so it really is like it's a typical mob
Shakedown the basic framework hasn't
changed but they sell it as brand safety
meaning your brand is in danger if you
don't do exactly what we say and stop
advertising with this website that we
don't like and we object to no matter
how much money it's making you and no
matter how much the audience actually
likes the content on that website and it
happens on a large scale that's exactly
the type of Shakedown that's happening
on Twitter now and I bet you that our
good friend Jonathan Greenblatt of the
ADL is hard at work making sure that
these potential advertisers and current
advertisers are sufficiently intimidated
but it happens on a smaller scale too to
a wide range of sites that distribute
content that the regime finds
objectionable and including yours
including mine in a very big way I have
one stalker woman who's absolutely
obsessed with me every time we get some
kind of new uh ad Arrangement she's she
has a a tweet Thread about it it's it's
really pathetic is she a blue check
I don't know about that I don't know
what the the her cast is and I don't
want I don't want to give her attention
so like by saying her name but we can
talk about her in the I don't like
giving but but this woman and I think
it's the same person went after a a
Weather Network like what yeah no no
joke no joke there's a a there's a cable
channel that does nothing but weather
and this leftist woman started like
tweeting about it and she's well like a
lot of these amount of followers her
friends in media write up her stories
and then she's actually getting
advertisers to pull off a weather
reporting station and it's like wow the
only thing on the screen is it says like
weather it's like raining in Texas like
that's the sad thing the sad thing is
how easily so many people cave because
usually they're liaison their point of
contact at these companies is like some
20-something woman who is ideologically
aligned and even if not all these
unsophisticated people need to hear is
the phrase conspiracy theory or you know
Trump or something like that and
automatically is like okay bad danger
you know that's all I need to hear or
even worse
or even worse than older woman without a
family that is there to complain as well
[Laughter]
thing that happened with the YouTube
adpocalypse is that what you're saying
that was really different well the model
they're saying oh the the brands who are
advertising mid-rolls on YouTube Can't
rely on whether the YouTube channels
they're advertised next to reflect their
brand values and I always thought that
was ridiculous on its face because
YouTube channels including this one are
Brands their companies in and of
themselves and they deserve to you know
have advertisers that align with their
values right but let's not forget at the
end of the day advertisers have a choice
to not advertise with certain creators
you could go as an Advertiser and you
could go into the Google settings and
say I don't like Alex Jones I don't like
you can choose that you could choose who
you advertise with than not and as a
content creator I could say hey I don't
want any advertisements for the US
military I don't want McDonald's
advertisements I don't want these kind
of politicians and these kind of ads
associated with my brand and I could do
that just like Mass is complaining right
now yes you can I I used to be able to
do that and I used to say I don't want
any McDonald's ads I don't want any
um you still do that
um
on YouTube uh on Google on Google on
your website you mean uh no no no on
Google there was a setting I remember
doing this for your YouTube channel I
remember doing this a few years ago
saying I don't want to advertise with I
don't want these advertisers on my
YouTube I don't know how to do that I I
could show you okay that's definitely
fair right but but but it's fair exactly
but but we don't hear about this a lot
of the people don't know that
advertisers have a choice and and if
they find someone despicable or they
don't want anyone tied in with their
associate they don't have to have it
they already have the infrastructure
that's not why they're pulling ads
they're pulling ads because the far left
marches around with bricks and
conservatives sitting there lazy boys
complaining that's it
so until law enforcement the the
solution and that's why they wanted to
fund the police partly why law
enforcement needs to stop these people
and we need to develop some kind of
system and stuff I notice the the
easiest example is
storefronts in Berkeley will put up all
the leftist signs in their window
because they know if someone throws a
brick through their window the cops
can't do anything about it like your car
can get stolen good luck the cop's gonna
be like well
we'll write down the we'll write down
the license plate and then if we see it
we'll let you know but if you've got
something like a bike your bike's gone
if you've got something like a moped
your moped is gone it's stolen the cops
show up and say what do you want to do
about it so if you piss off the far left
who are psychotic violent individuals
and they start harassing your neighbor
the cops are going to be like what do
you want us to do about it so what do
they do they say look
Dave Rubin is not going to March this is
the example I love given Dave Rubin is
never going to march to Twitter HQ to
complain about the censorship he's never
going to march with a bunch of classical
liberals carrying torches to YouTube HQ
to say no more censorship he's going to
go and he's going to complain about it
and that's all he's going to do antifa
will literally throw up with crowbars
and beat the crap out of people that
terrifies them so they say I know who to
avoid and who to cater to so these big
Brands when they hear that far leftists
are attacking them they immediately say
guys Red Alert do whatever they say and
they'll go away that's that's that's
that's it yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how Elon Musk kind of
navigates this very uh changing media
advertising landscape because right now
just a couple of minutes ago he's
promising Twitter being a good video
platform that's going to offer quote
according to Elon Musk higher
compensation for creators than YouTube
so this is something that Elon Musk just
tweeted a couple of moments ago
responding to Mr Beast how is he going
to be doing that specifically with so
many ad advertisers boycotting him will
there be other advertisers and also by
and large advertisers are pulling back
naturally not because of cancer culture
but because of the way that the economy
is just being absolutely screwed over
right now just how poorly it's doing
right now compared to everything else I
think Sargon got unbanned I think Rakata
and Sargon got on band during the Carl
Benjamin is back wow dude it's been so
long wow that's amazing this is what
people in the chat are saying yeah we
got a Super Chat someone just said it I
had to announce it uh Carl's awesome
he's a good friend he helped me actually
uh get all this stuff rolling when uh
when I started doing YouTube full-time
he hit me up and asked me if I would do
a guest spot on his channel he had like
300 000 subscribers I had like 40 and I
was like yeah for sure man I made a
video I ended up getting hundreds of
thousands of hits all of a sudden I
gained a whole bunch of subscribers and
it helped get the ball rolling so very
grateful to Carl Benjamin he's a good
dude he hosts Lotus Eaters podcasts glad
to see that he's he's been restored
finally after all these years yeah
literally to Twitter oh man this will be
fun apparently rakita law was like
literally during the show so yeah I know
just right now people are saying uh that
uh that that they're back great this is
amazing yeah so uh look I'll Elon man
wins a win I'll take it I'm not I'm I'm
not gonna ignore the problems I see with
the Alex Jones stuff but I will stress
it again hey man like this is a huge
Victory so take what you can get I
suppose and uh
and I'll roll with it I will say this
now too
there's a tough question about
do we give Elon the eight dollars
I'm leaning towards yes because I said
if he freed the political prisoners I
would sign up because I want the
features it's all good stuff and I want
to see Twitter succeed they they deleted
my ad campaign I tried advertising the
super Maga shirt it's where Trump's
going Super Saiyan and they said it was
political you can't do it I said okay so
I tried doing the rooster shirt and the
ad ran for like four hours and then they
took it down saying it was inappropriate
Elon I'm trying to give you money man
like what's going on here weiner jokes
it's a rooster it says stand your ground
I thought it was cool I'm like okay I'll
try this but anyway
I think uh The Alex Jones things is
unfortunate and I think elon's wrong and
I and for everything we described but
I'm going to take this win and we got to
see Twitter make it so I I think you
know it's time to sign up we already got
Tim cast news signed up we'll we'll get
our other accounts we'll get pop culture
pop culture crisis verified we'll get
all our business accounts verified I
think unbanning Sargon for me is kind of
like oh wow like he's a personal friend
you know so that says a lot yeah and we
also we also now know exactly why Alex
Jones is going back like now at least
elon's clarified his reasons for not
having him on the platform whether
they're not so sure he doesn't have
ulterior motives and he's just saying
that he's foreign
like what would be the game there
I have no idea he gives up the Alex
Jones Pawn but what other Pawn does he
get or like what more powerful than Elon
Musk that can threaten him financially
well he he has a very interesting
conflict with Bill Gates which I think
is fascinating to see unfold
um and and you know Tim you bring up a
good question it does kind of bring down
a different kind of Paradigm here do you
do you support him for doing all this
good when he did this one thing that's
bad it's it's a tough call for a lot of
people but I'm kind of leaning on like
hey he freed a lot of political
prisoners he's giving them a lot of
voices and for me I think that's worth
eight bucks it's a girlfriend probably
Elon Musk has some girlfriend on the
side who's like telling him you can't
you can't unband Alex Jones that must be
it that's more likely than anything
um
I don't think so women have powerful
persuasion I'm not I'm trying to get the
tweets to load on us our verbatas
but uh I don't see any tweets on
sargon's account maybe they got I think
people are saying in the comment section
that he's still sleeping you know what I
mean like his old tweets aren't back
either but I can see it's a big glitch
though and it's yeah because it's like
whenever they unban you it slowly comes
right keita only has a couple thousand
followers but they're slowly getting
back a lot of people were saying that
when Trump was back people weren't
allowed to follow him but but that
usually was happened when people were
reinstated it took a while until they're
all their followers and everything kind
of came back to normal I wonder if he's
gonna unban people who evade did
suspension and made new accounts like
over and over again it's it's been like
five years I think since Sargon got
banned thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time